the roman catholic church and the papacy
represents a deep wound for many
residential school survivors
and their families i've had to go to
therapy ever since i was a little kid
just because of the you know the
domestic violence and sexual violence uh
spiritual and emotional violence that
you know i grew up with in my family um
and uh you know and and and that's a
shared experience clayton thomas mueller
is very open about the intergenerational
effects of residential schools his
mother and father are both survivors for
him processing the pain has happened
through storytelling a pillar of his
cree culture a culture he had to learn
to love i remember telling kids in
kindergarten in grade one that i was
italian
because i felt so afraid to let people
know i was native an estimated 150
thousand children were exposed to the
abusive culturally and spiritually
destructive system that operated for
more than a century in canada
most of the churches were run by
catholics the government of canada
sincerely apologizes and asks the
forgiveness that apology from former
prime minister stephen harper came in
2008 a year later indigenous delegates
traveled to vatican city to meet with
pope benedict xvi he expressed sorrow
and offered his sympathies but did not
issue a formal apology
wob canoe was there with his father a
survivor my dad extended an eagle
feather to him knowing that that's a
symbol of indigenous spirituality and
the pope accepted it and a kind of uh a
a gesture i guess of mutual respect and
goodwill
and that interaction i think really you
know
helped my dad to find
some measure of closure canoe's uncle
also a survivor will be part of a group
of indigenous canadians in vatican city
for a historic visit beginning monday
the first to meet with the pope will be
the metis delegation
the hope this time is that the trip will
end with an official papal apology
crystal gomanson global news london